der tag des sports fand heuer am 19
september wieder auf dem wiener
heldenplatz statt
auf mein gewand
los geht's
die besucher der veranstaltung hatten
ihr gelegenheit spitzen sportler und
sportlerinnen persönlich kennenzulernen
interessierte konnten einige sportarten
ausprobieren und erfahrungsaustausch mit
aktiven sportlern pflegen
an diesem tag wird das bundesheer seine
erfolgreichen spitzensportlern
sportlerinnen mit dem militär is for zu
wort des jahres 2005 2005 kammer des
jahres schwimmend korporal lisa cesar
schönen applaus mannschaft des jahres
roth umzugs peter penz und georg
fischler schönen als unsere
sportlerin des jahres skeleton
kooperation in block schönen applaus
unsere ski weltcup siegerin und sportler
des jahres sprunghaft opera stefan kraft
gratulation an den stefan gratulation an
wolfgang kinder gratulation auch an dem
michael hübl